[Music]
the idea is to not let the ball get to
the middle of the floor so you can
continue your offense you isolate it on
one side
carter oh what a catch and finish
[Applause]
how far the mount saint mary's guards
are pushed out
swatted away by stewart the flip side
could be that washington's confident
play in arizona now you just beat him
less than a week ago a three from isaiah
stewart just his
fifth of the season dylan smith is lucky
that he's not in the emergency room
right now great defense oh stewart with
the one-handed
throwdown off the miss by hardy if he
goes in the late first round he might
[Applause]
determination focus commitment great
position in his life now to come and
make a fantastic
career for himself great play by jamal
they throw it down
one time stuart that's that limp
green with his eyes up oh what a catch
[Applause]
he had hands like a tight mjb all you
gotta do is throw it until he's gonna go
get it
he's been a major factor in the second
half knocked away
isaiah stewart racks up his second block
the other way up and under off the glass